all right you remember blue's clues
maybe your kids watched it maybe you
watched it
we all remember how steve abruptly left
the show yeah well this week the
original host steve burns he put the
striped shirt on again and left this
sweet video message online
you remember how when we were younger we
used to um
run around and hang out with blue and
find clues and talk to mr salt freak out
about the mail and do all the fun stuff
and then one day i was like oh hey guess
what big news i'm leaving
now that's of course just part of the
video burns goes on to explain in he
went to college the character did and
realizes that fast departure might have
been confusing for you when you were a
child
he says he's done a lot of growing up
just like the rest of us but that we
helped him become an adult and that he
never forgot about any of us
he actually after he left the show he
was in some
rock bands i think in new york something
along those lines but it was so
you know i i think blue's clues was
probably
uh a little younger than all four of us
really on the show but we were familiar
with it to see him come back and to talk
in that way was there was something very
heartwarming about it you know it was
cool in the morning well if you have if
you have kids like nate and i do we
watched a lot of blues clips absolutely
because steve was replaced by joe
yes his brother right it was his brother
where his cousin or something yeah
well no i i remember watching because i
would have to babysit my brothers and
they they loved blues here's the mail it
never fails yeah so mail time
[Laughter]
well done
and you know when you when you find
those uh this because we had uh blue we
had a stuffed blue for a long long time
and you don't want to part with those
because those are memories it's a part
of your childhood
good to see it steve's doing well 25th
anniversary
and the